This episode is brought to you by Defender. With a towing capacity of 3,500 kilograms and a waiting depth of 900 millimeters, the Defender 110 pushes what's possible. Learn more at landrover.ca. Bankmore on course when you switch to a Scotia Bank banking package. Learn more at scotiabank.com slash banking packages. Conditions apply. Scotia Beck, you're richer than you think.
本集由 Defender 赞助播出。Defender 110 拥有 3,500 公斤的拖曳能力和 900 毫米的涉水深度，不断突破无限可能。了解更多信息请访问 landrover.ca。换用丰业银行（Scotiabank）银行套餐，理财更顺心。了解更多信息请访问 scotiabank.com 斜杠 banking packages。适用相关条款。丰业银行，你比想象中更富有。
We have some fun merch news. Yes. We are back with a limited time, a pop-up merch store. Yes, and we have brand new Office Ladies merch for you. It is available September 3rd through September 17th. We've got some classic designs that we know you love, plus an all-new Scranton Hot collection. We also have a super cute Finer Things Club tote
我们有一些好玩的周边新闻。是的。我们带着限时快闪周边商店回归了。是的，我们为你准备了全新的“办公室女郎”周边。销售时间为 9 月 3 号到 9 月 17 号。我们不仅有大家喜爱的经典设计，还有全新的“斯克兰顿辣妹”系列。我们还有超级可爱的“更精致俱乐部”手提袋
and a water bottle that says Office Ladies sassy since 2019. So if you've been waiting for new Office Ladies merch for yourself, your best friend, your sister, your mom, your hubby, now's your chance. Head to ShopOffofficeLadies.com and get your order in today. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lover's. podcast just for you. Each week, we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0.
以及一个印有“办公室女郎，自 2019 年起风情万种”字样的水杯。所以，如果你一直在为自己、你的最好朋友、你的姐姐、你的妈妈、你的老公等待新的“办公室女郎”周边，现在机会来了。快去 ShopOffofficeLadies.com 网站，今天就把订单下好吧。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，我们是好朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极版办公室爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量的闺蜜故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是 6.0 版本的办公室女郎。
Hello. Hi there. Aw. I'm wearing one of my mom's really old necklaces from back in the day, like back in like the 70s. Really? That looks brand new. It's not. It looks, wow. Isn't that cool? It's gorgeous. It's long. It's long. Long, it hangs well low below the ladies. Yeah, it's like a long. What do they call those? I don't know, but I normally don't wear them. Am I a certain age now that I'm wearing the long necklace? I mean, it goes almost to my belly button. No. I went through a phase where I wore all long necklaces for a while. Oh, okay. I just kind of liked it. Well, it's a nice look. Thank you. I have got it hung up on a few things. Like I've been over and it hung up on the
你好。嗨。哦。我戴着我妈妈很久以前的一条旧项链，大概是 70 年代的那种。真的吗？看起来像全新的一样。并不是。看起来，哇。不是很酷吗？真漂亮。很长。很长。很长，它垂在胸前挺低的。对，就像一条很长的。他们管那叫什么？我不知道，但我通常不戴这种。我是到了某个年纪才开始戴长项链吗？我的意思是，它几乎垂到我的肚脐眼了。没有。我曾经有一段时间疯狂迷恋所有长项链。哦，好吧。我只是觉得挺好看的。嗯，这个造型挺不错的。谢谢。我有几回把它勾到别的东西上了。就像我弯腰的时候，它勾住了
the handle of the drawer. Yes. Yes, exactly. Okay. Well, I wore it. In honor of this episode today, I wore a statement necklace in honor of Phyllis. Oh, I love that lady. Today is all about Phyllis Lappin, and we have a great episode for you. And I'm really excited for this one because we reached out to Phyllis and she gave us a bunch of good nuggets about playing Phyllis. It was so lovely to hear from her. And I loved the questions everyone sent in.
抽屉的把手。是的。没错，就是这样。好吧。我戴着它，为了向今天的这一集致敬，我戴了一条抢眼的项链，向菲莉丝致敬。哦，我太喜欢那位女士了。今天的主角全是菲莉丝·拉平，我们为您准备了一集精彩的内容。我真的为这一集感到兴奋，因为我们联系了菲莉丝，她给我们提供了一堆关于扮演菲莉丝的好料。听到她的消息真是太棒了。而且我很喜欢大家发来的问题。
They're always so thoughtful. Well, as you know, we like to kick off these episodes with a little show by Bible summary. And you know what? The character of Phyllis was really fun, but her show Bible section is very short. Oh, it's only three pages. I think it might be the shortest one. Wow. Yeah. But here we go. Let's hear it. It says Phyllis Vance, formerly Lapin, is a sales rep. Her address, per the art department, because we never saw this on screen, was 104 Kimberly Circle, Scranton, Pennsylvania. Now, I don't know. if that's also where Bob Vance lives. We don't know. Sounds fancy. Yeah, we don't know if it's their home together or not. Phyllis drives a maroon Chevy Malibu. She is a member of the
大家总是思虑周全。好了，正如你所知，我们喜欢用一点节目圣经总结来开启这些节目。你知道吗？菲莉丝这个角色真的很有趣，但她的节目圣经部分非常简短。哦，只有三页。我想这可能是最短的一个了。哇。是的。不过，我们开始吧。上面写着，菲莉丝·Vance，原姓拉平，是一名销售代表。根据艺术部门的记录，她的住址是宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿金伯利圆环 104 号，因为我们在屏幕上从来没见过这个地址。现在，我不知道。这也是鲍勃·凡斯住的地方吗？我们不知道。听起来很高级。是的，我们不知道这是不是他们共同的家。菲莉丝开一辆褐红色雪佛兰 Malibu。她是
party planning committee. She's Lutheran. And then here's what's interesting about the show Bible for Phyllis. We know a lot about her life when she was younger. And we know a lot about her sex life. I didn't know how to say it. You paused and I didn't know where you were going. So these are the main categories that we know about Phyllis. For example, per Michael, her nickname in high school, was Easy Rider. Oh, my gosh. But he also makes a point to say that she was cute and caring and always had a big heart. Phyllis finds roleplay fun. She can put on lipstick the way Molly Ringwald does in the breakfast club where it's like tucked in her bra. Yes. After you saw that movie, did you try to do it?
派对策划委员会成员。她是路德宗。然后，关于菲莉丝的节目圣经，有趣的是这一点。我们对她年轻时的生活了解很多。而且我们对她的性生活了解很多。我当时不知道该怎么说。你停顿了一下，我不知道你要扯到哪里去。所以，这些是我们了解菲莉丝的主要类别。例如，根据迈克尔的说法，她在高中时的绰号是“逍遥骑士”。哦，天哪。但他也特意指出，她很可爱、很有爱心，而且一直都有一颗善良的心。菲莉丝觉得角色扮演很有趣。她可以像《早餐俱乐部》里的莫莉·林沃德那样涂口红，就是把它塞在胸衣里。是的。你看了那部电影之后，尝试过这样做吗？
I couldn't do it. Yes, I tried. We all tried to do it. Yeah. I couldn't do it. Could you do it? No. She has a long lipstick tube, too, though. Like she has a skinny long lipstick tube. I think that helps. I don't know who can do that. Well, she did it in the movie. There was no CGI there, I don't think. No. Didn't have that back then. All right. Continuing with Phyllis, Phyllis never had an orgasm until she was 42. And when she did, it lasted until she was 44. She, Didn't get much done when she was 43. That's something I'm bringing up later. Oh my gosh. Same. The show Bible doesn't say anything about college, but it does note that she was in a sorority. And also that she had scoliosis as a child and she grinds her teeth. Oh.
我做不到。是的，我试过。我们都试过。是的。我做不到。你能做到吗？不能。不过她用的口红管也很长。就像她有一支细长的口红管。我想这有帮助。我不知道谁能做到那点。不过她在电影里做到了。我觉得里面没有电脑特效。没有。那时候可没有那种技术。好的。关于菲莉丝，继续说，菲莉丝在 42 岁之前从未体验过高潮。而当她体验到时，一直持续到了 44 岁。她，在 43 岁时没干成什么事。这是我一会儿要提的事情。哦，天哪。我也是。节目圣经里没提任何关于大学的事，但它确实指出她加入过一个姐妹会。还有，她小时候患过脊柱侧弯，而且她会磨牙。哦。
Yes. Phyllis uses perfumy soaps and likes perfumes in general. She also likes purple and would-do gym. Would do gym? Yeah. I thought at first she meant like she would go to the gym. But then I realized do gym is Jim Jim Jim. Jim helper. Got it. Phyllis can knit. She would really like a big walk in closet. She loves girl talk, but she doesn't like Angela. Not a lot. This is in the show Bible repeatedly, by the way. Like every episode where Phyllis says she doesn't like you is listed in the show Bible. It's very funny. Does my character make up the majority for show. Bible? It's a good portion of it, yes. Phyllis has four sisters, is a good bowler, and she once had a baby that she gave up for adoption. That is the Phyllis Show Bible. That was short and tight there. It was. Well, I thought we should also break down a big part of Phyllis's character, and that is her wardrobe choices. She has an iconic look. And, you know, I did this for all about
是的。菲莉丝用带香味的肥皂，总体上喜欢香水。她也喜欢紫色，而且会去健身。会去健身？对。我一开始以为她的意思是她会去健身房。但后来我意识到“do gym”就是 Jim Jim Jim。吉姆·哈珀。明白了。菲莉丝会织毛衣。她真的很想要一个超大的步入式衣帽间。她喜欢女生闲聊，但她不喜欢安吉拉。不太喜欢。顺便说一句，节目圣经里反复提到了这一点。比如菲莉丝说她不喜欢你的每一集都被列在了节目圣经里。这太搞笑了。我的角色占了节目圣经的大部分吗？占了很大一部分，是的。菲莉丝有四个姐妹，保龄球打得很好，她曾经生过一个孩子并送去领养了。这就是菲莉丝的节目圣经。刚才那段既简短又干练。确实。好吧，我觉得我们也应该剖析一下菲莉丝这个角色的一个重要部分，那就是她的服装选择。她有着标志性的造型。而且，你知道的，我为“关于
Angela Martin. I loved it. And I definitely thought we had to do it for Phyllis. So here is my guide on how to dress like Phyllis. You told me we were going to do this and I was delighted. It's so silly, but I really, really love people's like costumes and how that informs them. All right, number one, typically you will need some type of sweater cardigan over a blouse, a long flowing skirt, some sensible shoes. Most importantly, you are going to need a big pop of color, maybe coral. are purple. In fact, you can't go wrong with purple ever. Remember, Phyllis was called Mother Goose because of her purple ensemble by Sasha Flanderson. I mean, I just told you it's literally
安吉拉·马丁”做过这个。我当时很喜欢。我绝对觉得我们得为菲莉丝也做一次。所以，这就是我关于如何穿得像菲莉丝的指南。你告诉我我们要这么做的时候，我简直高兴坏了。这太傻了，但我真的、真的很喜欢人们的服装以及这些服装是如何塑造他们的。好吧，第一点，通常你需要在衬衫外面穿某种开衫毛衣、一条长长的飘逸裙子、一双得体的鞋子。最重要的是，你需要一个醒目的亮色，比如珊瑚色。或紫色。事实上，穿紫色永远不会出错。记住，萨莎·弗兰德森因为菲莉丝的紫色套装而称她为“鹅妈妈”。我的意思是，我刚刚才告诉过你，这
in her show bubble that she loves purple. She loves purple. You are also going to need to work in some bold prints. Yeah. You can't be afraid of like a little bit of print action. Yeah. Yeah. Print action. I like that. Print action. You're going to need a cute pair of reading glasses. maybe some with a purple rim, and some type of small earring like gold hoops. A delicate gold wrist watch. And lastly, but not least, you will always want a statement necklace to complement your outfit. It might have big bobbles or beads. It's definitely going to color coordinate with your cardigan. And that's how you dress like Phyllis. I think Phyllis wants a big walk-in closet just for all of her statement necklaces.
字面意思就写在她的节目圣经里，她喜欢紫色。她非常喜欢紫色。你还需要融入一些大胆的印花。是的。你不能害怕那种带点印花的服装。对。对。印花服装。我喜欢这个。印花服装。你需要一副可爱的老花镜。也许有些是紫色边框的，还有某种小耳环，比如金色圆环。一块精致的金色手表。最后但同样重要的是，你总是需要一条抢眼的项链来衬托你的服装。它可能会有大圆球或串珠。它绝对会跟你的开衫颜色协调。这就是如何穿得像菲莉丝。我觉得菲莉丝想要一个超大的步入式衣帽间，纯粹是为了放她所有的抢眼项链。
She would have probably one of those hooks that comes out with little like knobs and you could hang them all there. Yeah. Like men do with ties, but it would just be her necklaces. How do you hang your necklaces? Oh, lady. This is so exciting. What? I didn't realize you'd be so excited by this question.
她大概会有一个那种拉出来带有小挂钩的架子，然后你可以把它们全都挂在上面。是的。就像男士挂领带那样，但全都是她的项链。你是怎么挂你的项链的？哦，天哪。这太让人兴奋了。什么？我没想到你对这个问题会这么兴奋。
Okay. I have never been asked this. I think I shared it once on Instagram like a gazillion years ago. But, okay, I got an old dresser at a flea market. It's like, supposedly from France, who knows. But it's old. Like the drawers don't quite come out right, you know. But it was like a dressing chest, okay?
好吧。从来没有人问过我这个。我想我好几百万年前在 Instagram 上分享过一次。但是，好吧，我在跳蚤市场买了一个旧梳妆台。据说，是来自法国的，谁知道呢。但它很旧。就像抽屉拉出来不太顺畅那种，你知道的。但它像是一个梳妆柜，好吧？
So it's got these two doors. There's probably a better name for it. A dressing chest is probably not it. But it's got these two doors at the top that open. And then it's got little drawers that you pull out. So I made the little drawers that you pull out my jewelry stuff. You know, I went to the container store. I got all these little cubby things.
所以它有两扇门。可能有个更好听的名字。梳妆柜可能不太对。但它顶部有两扇可以打开的门。然后它有可以拉出来的小抽屉。所以我把那些可以拉出来的小抽屉当作我的首饰盒了。你知道的，我去了集装箱商店。我买了所有这些小格子东西。
like put all the stuff in. And then the doors, when you open them, I got those tiny little command strip hooks. Yeah. They're like clear. And they were tiny. They're like the size of your fingernail. And I lined the doors on the inside with them. And that's where I hang my necklaces. I am so glad I asked this question. I've never seen you so excited. Well, it was like a whole DIY project I did one day. I was so annoyed that like my necklaces get tangled and I have some from my mom and, you know, some things I don't want messed up. And I'm like, where do I put them? I just got, like, they were like rows of, like Home Depot or Lowe's or something. I don't even know where. And it was like, it's like a wooden thing that you like screw into the
把所有的东西都放进去。然后那些门，当你打开它们的时候，我用了那些极小的指挥官挂钩。是的。它们是透明的。而且它们非常小。大概只有你的指甲盖那么大。我用它们沿着门的内侧排了一圈。那就是我挂项链的地方。我太庆幸我问了这个问题了。我从来没见你这么兴奋过。好吧，这就像是我有一天做的一个完整的 DIY 项目。我很烦恼我的项链总是缠在一起，而且我有些是妈妈留给我的，你知道的，有些东西我不想弄坏。我就想，我把它们放哪儿呢？我只是买了一些，就像家得宝（Home Depot）或劳氏（Lowe's）那类地方买的一排排东西。我甚至不知道是在哪儿买的。就像是一个木质的东西，你可以把它拧到
wall and it has like little hooks on it. I've seen those. And I put a couple of those on the wall in my closet, but it's not sufficient. They, I only have eight hooks and my necklaces get all tangled. Well, I'll take a picture of it and show it to you. I'll share it in stories if anyone else wants to try my DIY necklace trick. The next time I come to your house, I want to see it in person. Okay. Before we move on from Phyllis's wardrobe, I do want you to know that there was a ranking of best dress the office characters, and guess where Phyllis came in? Oh, she's got to be top five. Oh, yeah. Number two. Number two.
墙上，上面有小钩子。我见过那种。我在我衣帽间的墙上装了几个那样的东西，但完全不够。它们，我只有八个钩子，我的项链全都缠在一起了。好吧，我拍张照片给你看看。如果还有谁想尝试我的 DIY 项链小窍门，我会把它分享到快拍里。下次我再去你家的时候，我要亲眼看看。好的。在我们结束菲莉丝的穿搭话题之前，我确实想让你知道，办公室角色最佳着装有一个排名，你猜菲莉丝排在第几名？哦，她绝对在前五名。哦，是的。第二名。第二名。
Yeah. Who is number one? Who do you think? Kelly? Joe Bennett. Oh, that's good. Right? Yes, very good.
是的。谁是第一名？你觉得是谁？凯莉？乔·贝内特。哦，那挺好的。对吧？是的，非常好。
There's also websites that can help you create the office character's most iconic looks. I found a really easy DIY costume guide on Good Housekeeping's website, and I'll put that in stories, too. That'd be good for Halloween. I know. Before we go to break, we have some fun merch news. Yes. You might have noticed that our old merch store close. But good news, we are back with a limited time pop-up merch store.
还有一些网站可以帮助你打造《办公室》角色的最具标志性造型。我在美好家园（Good Housekeeping）的网站上找到了一个非常简单的 DIY 服装指南，我也会把它发到快拍里。万圣节用这个会很不错。我知道。在我们进入广告休息之前，我们有一些好玩的周边新闻。是的。你可能已经注意到我们以前的周边商店关闭了。但好消息是，我们带着限时快闪周边商店回归了。
Yes, and we have brand new Office Ladies merch for you. It is available starting today, September 3rd through September 17th. We've got some classic designs that we know you love, plus an all-new Scranton Hot collection. Yes, remember when Lindsay Broad was on? She shared that Scranton Hot was how they described Kathy in the casting breakdown. Well, all of you suggested that we make some merch with that phrase, and it turned out so cute. We also have a super cute, Finer Things Club tote and a water bottle that says Office Ladies sassy since 2019. So if you've been waiting for new Office Ladies merch for yourself, your best friend, your sister, your mom, your hubby, now's your chance.
是的，我们为你准备了全新的“办公室女郎”周边。从今天开始发售，也就是 9 月 3 号到 9 月 17 号。我们有大家喜爱的经典设计，还有全新的“斯克兰顿辣妹”系列。是的，还记得琳赛·布罗德来做客的时候吗？她分享说，“斯克兰顿辣妹”是他们在试镜分析中用来形容凯茜的词。好吧，你们所有人都建议我们用那个短语制作一些周边，结果做出来太可爱了。我们还有一个超级可爱的“更精致俱乐部”手提袋和一个印有“办公室女郎，自 2019 年起风情万种”字样的水杯。所以，如果你一直在为自己、你的最好朋友、你的姐姐、你的妈妈、你的老公等待新的“办公室女郎”周边，现在就是你的机会。
Head to ShopOffofficeLadies.com and get your order in today. So just to be clear, this is just a pop-up store, and it's only available from September 3rd to September 17th. I just want to say thank you for your suggestions. And we'll be looking to see if you have any more suggestions because we're going to do another one of these like around the holidays, right, Angela? Yes, you can write us in our general mail folder on our website if you have any merch ideas for our next pop-up store. And happy shopping. We'll be right back. We want to talk to you guys a little bit about the ego protein waffle.
快去 ShopOffofficeLadies.com 网站，今天就把你的订单下好吧。所以为了说清楚，这只是一家快闪店，而且只从 9 月 3 号开放到 9 月 17 号。我只想说谢谢你们的建议。我们也会看看你们是否还有更多建议，因为我们打算在假期前后再做一次这样的活动，对吧，安吉拉？是的，如果你对我们的下一家快闪店有什么周边创意，你可以在我们网站的综合邮箱文件夹里写信给我们。祝大家购物愉快。我们马上回来。我们想跟你们聊聊 Eggo 蛋白华夫饼。
You and I both love ego waffles. Yes. Our kids love ego waffles. And listen, if you have teenagers, they're so on the go in the morning. My daughter will just grab one, like wrap it up in a paper towel and eat it as she walks through the house. Yes. For sure. And now there are new ego protein waffles and pancakes.
你和我都很喜欢 Eggo 华夫饼。是的。我们的孩子也很喜欢 Eggo 华夫饼。听着，如果你有十几岁的青少年，他们在早晨总是行色匆匆。我女儿会直接拿一个，用纸巾包起来，一边在屋里走一边吃。是的。确实如此。现在有了全新的 Eggo 蛋白华夫饼和煎饼。
Here's the deal. You've got the same great flavor, but now you have twice. 20% of your daily protein. Yeah, and they taste really good. I made the new egg-o-protein waffles for my kids the other day. They didn't even know that they were protein waffles. They're just the egg-o waffles that you know and love. Also, the flavors are so good.
情况是这样的。你依然能享受到同样美妙的美味，但现在你的蛋白质摄入量翻倍了。占你每日蛋白质摄入量的 20%。是的，而且它们味道真的很好。前几天我给孩子们做了新款 Eggo 蛋白华夫饼。他们甚至不知道那是蛋白华夫饼。它们就是你所熟悉和热爱的那些 Eggo 华夫饼。而且，口味太棒了。
You can do buttermilk vanilla or chocolate chip brownie. We like the buttermilk vanilla, and you know what we put on them instead of syrup? What? I cut up strawberries. Oh, yeah, my kids love strawberries on them. And I put strawberries on top, and you can draw. rizzle a little honey, it's so good. You know, it can make your breakfast complete and give your kids the protein they need. And it means I don't have to like scramble something up or fry something up.
你可以选择酪乳香草味或巧克力豆布朗尼味。我们喜欢酪乳香草味，你知道我们不在上面浇糖浆，而是放什么吗？什么？我切了草莓。哦，对，我孩子们喜欢在上面放草莓。我在上面放上草莓，你还可以淋上一
That's right. I don't have to dirty a pan. Oh, that's always a big bonus. In the mornings. No, it's not at all. I mean, listen, I know we're talking about breakfast, but they're a great afternoon snack too. I have shared this before. I like them as an afternoon treat. And when your teenagers come home hungry, guess what's real easy to give them? A little protein waffle. Head to your local grocery store to fuel your morning with ego protein waffles and pancakes available at retailers nationwide. Hi, I'm Feminacity Erin Gibson. And I'm Homosexual Brian Safi. And we're the co-hosts of the Attitudes podcast where we talk about LGBT plus issues, gender issues, and pop culture. Probably with much less respect than they deserve. Look, it's a wild world and we want to help you
点点蜂蜜，太好吃了。你知道的，它能让你的早餐完美，并为孩子们提供他们所需的蛋白质。这意味着我不用手忙脚乱地炒点什么或煎点什么了。没错。我不用弄脏平底锅。哦，那一直是个巨大的福利。在早晨。不，完全不是。听着，我知道我们在谈论早餐，但它们也是很棒的下午点心。我以前分享过这个。我喜欢把它们当作下午的慰藉。当你的十几岁孩子放学回家觉得饿时，你猜给他们吃什么最简单？一个小蛋白华夫饼。前往你当地的杂货店，用 Eggo 蛋白华夫饼和煎饼开启你充满能量的早晨，全国各大零售商均有销售。嗨，我是女权主义者埃琳·吉布森。我是同性恋者布莱恩·萨菲。我们是《态度》播客的联合主持人，在这里我们讨论 LGBTQ 加号议题、性别议题和流行文化。可能比它们应得的尊重要少得多。听着，这是一个疯狂的世界，我们想帮你
laugh at it. Plus, we discuss everything going on in our lives. Like, what do you do when your husband accidentally starts a fire in a dumpster? And the best armpit slapping techniques to get rid of the bags under your eyes. Thanks for the advice, Mom. And of course, how to spend a wig around to achieve a brand new look. Oh, stunning. So if you're a fan of high-heel shoe chairs or have a crippling fear of hot air balloons but also believe in social justice, then this show's for you. Listen to attitudes anywhere you get your podcasts. This show is fine. sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, sometimes we turn to some funny places for support. Maybe a hairdresser, a barista, maybe a random stranger in the bathroom for life advice, but not everyone is a therapist.
嘲笑它。此外，我们讨论生活中发生的一切。比如，当你的老公不小心在垃圾箱里引发了一场火灾时，你该怎么办？以及为了消除眼袋而采用的最佳拍打腋窝技巧。谢谢你的建议，妈妈。当然，还有如何甩动假发来打造全新造型。哦，太惊艳了。所以，如果你是高跟鞋造型椅的粉丝，或者对热气球有着莫名的恐惧，但同时也信仰社会公正，那么这个节目就是为你准备的。在任何你收听播客的地方收听《态度》。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助播出。你知道的，有时候我们会去一些奇怪的地方寻求支持。也许是发型师、咖啡师，或是浴室里的某个陌生人来获取生活建议，但并不是每个人都是治疗师。
You can find your right match with BetterHelp. BetterHelp therapists are clinically trained and credentialed. They work according to a strict code of conduct and are fully licensed in the U.S. And BetterHelp does the initial matching work for you, so you can focus on your therapy goals. You'll get a short questionnaire that helps identify your needs and preferences, and then they will match you with a licensed therapist. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Find the one with BetterHelp.
你可以通过 BetterHelp 找到真正适合你的人。BetterHelp 的治疗师都经过临床培训并持有资质。他们遵循严格的行为准则，并在美国拥有完全的执业资格。BetterHelp 会为你完成最初的匹配工作，这样你就可以专注于你的治疗目标。你会得到一份简短的问卷，帮助确定你的需求和偏好，然后他们会为你匹配一位持证治疗师。作为全球最大的在线心理治疗提供商，BetterHelp 可以为你提供拥有各种专业专长的心理健康专业人士。通过 BetterHelp 找到对的人。
Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. We are back, and I think we should start this section by each sharing our favorite Phyllis moment. Well, I can kick things off with a fan letter. We got this letter from KDE in North Carolina who said, there is one Phyllis moment that makes me laugh out loud every time I see it and giggle every time I think about it. In season four, episode 10, The Finer Things Club is gathered in the break room. Phyllis is trying her best to microwave some popcorn.
我们的听众在 BetterHelp.com 斜杠 office ladies 首次订阅可享九折优惠。网址是 BetterHelp，H-E-L-P.com 斜杠 office ladies。我们回来了，我觉得我们应该以各自分享最喜欢的菲莉丝时刻来开启这一段。好吧，我可以从一封粉丝来信开始。我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州 KDE 的这封信，信中写道：“有一个菲莉丝时刻，每一次我看到它都会放声大笑，每一次我想起它都会咯咯直笑。在第四季第 10 集里，‘更精致俱乐部’聚集在休息室里。菲莉丝正尽力用微波炉加热一些爆米花。
In the process, she pushes many buttons, both the microwaves and Oscars. I love that every time you think that surely she's done, here comes some more beeps. I listen to your podcast nearly every day while eating lunch, and I so look forward to your breakdown of the hilarious and lovable Phyllis. In the meantime, you can find me giggling in the corner of my kitchen every time I press a few too many buttons on the microwave. That scene is so funny, Katie. I'm right there with you. Well, let's see. Who wants to go first? Sam, you want to share your favorite Phyllis moment? Yeah, mine's pretty self-explanatory.
在这个过程中，她按了许多按钮，既有微波炉的，也有奥斯卡的。我太喜欢这种感觉了：每当你以为她肯定按完了，紧接着又是一阵哔哔声。我几乎每天吃午饭时都会听你们的播客，我太期待你们对搞笑又可爱的菲莉丝的剖析了。在此期间，每当我在微波炉上多按了几个按钮时，你都会发现我正躲在厨房角落里咯咯直笑。”那一幕太搞笑了，凯蒂。我完全懂你。好吧，让我们看看。谁想先来？萨姆，你想分享你最喜欢的菲莉丝时刻吗？对，我的那个挺一目了然的。
I wonder what people like about me. Probably my jugs. Yes, I remember that. That's a really good one. Cassie? One of my favorite episodes is when Phyllis and Bob Vance, the Vance Refrigeration, have lunch or dinner with Jim and Pam, and they obviously go hook up in the bathroom and come back,
我想知道人们喜欢我什么。大概是我的大胸吧。对，我记得那个。那真的是个很经典的一段。卡西？我最喜欢的其中一集是，菲莉丝和凡斯制冷公司的鲍勃·凡斯跟吉姆和帕姆一起吃午餐或晚餐，他们显然去洗手间里鬼混了一番，然后回来了，
and Phyllis is like chugging water and is super flushed. But, of course, that's very visual. So as a nod to that, here's one of my favorite talking heads where she's talking about her relationship with Bob. Yeah, I love going to bars with Bob. I tend to wear something low cut, get men to flirt with me, and Bob beats them up. I mean, relationship goals, right? They're so, like, twisted. All right.
菲莉丝在一边猛灌水，脸涨得通红。但当然，那是极其视觉化的。所以为了向那个桥段致敬，这里有我最喜欢的一个采访镜头，她在里面谈到了她和鲍勃的关系。对，我喜欢和鲍勃一起去酒吧。我往往会穿低胸一点的衣服，让男人来跟我调情，然后鲍勃就会把他们揍一顿。我的意思是，这就是所谓的恋爱目标，对吧？他们俩简直是，呃，太变态了。好吧。
Well, mine is a talking head that Phyllis has in The Secrets. Santa episode. And I think I love it for so many reasons. One, I just love it because of my friend Phyllis, and I knew how special that episode was for her, that she was in the main storyline, that she was driving scenes, and she just rose to the occasion and she did such a great job. Phyllis and I used to run our lines together in our trailers when we had a lot of lines. So I have that, you know, in my head when I watched this episode. But then, also, it's just a great talking head. And you can hear how much it meant to Phyllis to be Secret Santa. Let's hear it. Oh, ho, ho. Merry Christmas boys and girls. It's me, Santa Claus.
嗯，我最喜欢的是菲莉丝在“秘密圣诞老人”那一集里的一个采访镜头。我觉得我喜欢它有很多原因。第一，我只是因为我的朋友菲莉丝而喜欢它，我知道那一集对她来说有多特别，她进入了主线剧情，她在推动剧情发展，她不负众望，表现得太出色了。以前我们有很多台词时，菲莉丝和我经常在我们的化妆车里对台词。所以当我观看这一集时，我脑子里就有那种（记忆）。但除此之外，这也是一个非常棒的采访镜头。你能听出成为秘密圣诞老人对菲莉丝来说意味着多少。我们来听听看。哦，哦，哦。圣诞快乐，男孩女孩们。是我，圣诞老人。
Hey, Santa. They finally let you do it. Congrats, Phil. It's so edgy. I have been wanting to be Santa for years. I believe I have the right temperament and the figure to do the job well. I slipped a note to Jim 11 weeks ago. I slipped a note to Jim 11 weeks ago. And he said I could do it. Oh, it's been a long journey. But I'm Santa Claus. Oh, my gosh. I love it so much. Isn't that so great?
嘿，圣诞老人。他们终于让你演了。恭喜啊，菲尔。太酷炫了。我多年来一直想扮演圣诞老人。我相信我有合适的气质和身材把这份工作做好。我在 11 周前塞给吉姆一张便条。我在 11 周前塞给吉姆一张便条。他说我可以演。哦，这是一段漫长的旅程。但我现在是圣诞老人了。哦，天哪。我太喜欢了。是不是超棒？
Yes. And I just love that you hear everyone's excitement for her as she comes in, you know, in her Santa Claus outfit. I just love that moment. Okay, well, my favorite Phyllis moment is the scene that, I did with her in Dunder Mifflin Infinity Part 1. Mm-hmm. So this is the episode where everyone has found out that Jim and Pam are dating. Pam and Jim are sitting in the break room and they're having lunch and Phyllis comes in.
是的。我特别喜欢听大家在她穿着圣诞老人服装走进来时为她欢呼雀跃的声音，你知道的。我太喜欢那个时刻了。好吧，我最喜欢的菲莉丝时刻是我在“当米夫林无限公司，第一部分”中与她演对手戏的那个场景。嗯哼。所以这是每个人都发现吉姆和帕姆在约会的那一集。帕姆和吉姆正坐在休息室里吃午饭，菲莉丝走了进来。
And we could not get through this scene because she was so funny. Here it is. Oh, I'm sorry. I didn't know you guys were in here. I don't know. We're just sitting here. I couldn't see your hands. Hey, Pam.
我们当时简直没法把这场戏拍完，因为她实在是太搞笑了。这就是那一幕。哦，对不起。我不知道你们俩在这儿。没事。我们只是坐在这儿。我没看到你们的手。嘿，帕姆。
By the way, it's great that you're dating. But when a new client calls, you just have to randomly assign them to a salesperson. You can't base who gets new clients on who you're sleeping with that week. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. And that is why we waited so long to tell people.
顺便说一句，你们在约会这很好。但当新客户打电话来时，你不能只是随机把他们分派给某个销售员。你不能把谁能得到新客户建立在你那一周跟谁上床的基础上。好吧。好吧。好吧。好吧。这就是为什么我们花了这么长时间才告诉别人。
The sats. There were two things that were so funny. So one, both of our hands are on the table. When she says, I couldn't see her hand. And John did this gesture where he was. he, like, after she says it, we look at each other and he holds up his hands to the camera, it's so funny. But we could barely get through that line when she said it. And then, of course, the second line is when she said, based on who you're sleeping with, that week. Like,
好家伙。有两件事太搞笑了。第一，当我们说“我没看到她的手”时，我们的手都放在桌上。约翰做了一个手势，他在她说完这句话后，我们互相看了一眼，然后他把双手举向镜头，太搞笑了。但当她说出那句话时，我们几乎快演不下去了。然后，当然，第二台词是当她说“基于你那一周跟谁上床”的时候。就像，
that little bit, it just every time. She just, like, doubles down on the snark. It's so good. So good. Well, I loved all of that. And this really transitions nicely into my area of interest lady. Okay. What was it? mine is best Phyllis one-liners. So the fans of the office love a good Phyllis one-liner. There's a lot of like threads online about it. And I found an article that lists them and here's what it said. While Phyllis Fance is known for her soft-spoken demeanor, she often delivers unexpectedly sharp, biting remarks. Her ability to blend sweetness with a surprising sting made her an underrated master of the one-liner on the office.
那个小包袱，每一次都这样。她只是，呃，变本加厉地刻薄。太棒了。太棒了。好吧，我很喜欢所有这些。这真的很自然地过渡到了我感兴趣的领域。好吧。是什么？我的是：菲莉丝最佳金句。所以《办公室》的粉丝们很喜欢菲莉丝的精彩金句。网上有很多关于这个的讨论串。我找到了一篇文章列出了这些金句，内容是这样的：虽然菲莉丝·凡斯以轻声细语的为人风格而闻名，但她经常爆出意料之外的尖锐、刻薄的言论。她将甜美与出人意料的尖刻完美融合的能力，使她成为了《办公室》里被低估的金句大师。
The list in this article was very long. She has a lot of really good one-liners, but I thought I'd read you guys my favorites, and some of yours might be on here. Okay. Number one in the article was, close your mouth, sweetie. You'll look like a trout.
这篇文章里的列表很长。她有很多非常精彩的金句，但我想读给你们听听我最喜欢的，你们的一些最爱可能也在上面。好的。文章排在第一位的是：闭上嘴，亲爱的。你看上去像条虹膜。
I knew that was going to be, number one. I knew it. I knew it. Okay. Number two. as a person who buys a lot of erotic cakes, it just feels good to be represented on one. So good. How many erotic cakes is this woman buying?
我早就知道那会是第一名。我早就知道了。我早就知道了。好的。第二名。作为一个经常购买色情蛋糕的人，能在一个蛋糕上被代表感觉真好。太棒了。这个女人到底在买多少色情蛋糕？
I don't know, but I almost picked that scene as my favorite Phyllis moment because it's very funny to me. That's the episode where she finally gets to run the party planning committee and Meredith wants to get an erotic cake. And Angela doesn't. And Phyllis is like, I'd like to hear her out. Yeah. You know what's so funny is that, um, When I first moved to Los Angeles, I had an apartment in West Hollywood. And right on Santa Monica Boulevard, there was an erotic cake shop.
我不知道，但我差点把那个场景选作我最喜欢的菲莉丝时刻，因为我觉得它太搞笑了。那是她终于有机会管理派对策划委员会的那一集，梅雷迪思想要一个色情蛋糕。而安吉拉不想。菲莉丝就说，我想听听她的想法。是的。你知道最搞笑的是什么吗？当我刚搬到洛杉矶时，我在西好莱坞有一间公寓。就在圣莫尼卡大道上，有一家色情蛋糕店。
And it was just a few doors down from the Ramada Inn where my mom and dad would always stay. Is this the only thing they made at this cake shop? Yes. There's that many people ordering erotic cakes so you can dedicate a whole business to it. I mean, it was a tiny little storefront. I don't know if it's still there. But my mom and dad would stay at the Ramada Inn. And my dad, you know, would get up at like 4.30 in the morning.
而且它离我爸妈总是住的华美达酒店只有几门之隔。这家蛋糕店里制作的只有这种东西吗？是的。有那么多人订购色情蛋糕，以至于你可以为它专门开一整家店吗？我的意思是，那是一个非常小的店面。我不知道它现在还在不在。但我爸妈会住在华美达酒店。我爸呢，你知道的，他早上 4:30 就会起床。
morning. He's such an early riser. Like, you know, 5 a.m. He's out. He's dressed. He's taking a walk. And I forgot about the erotic cake store. And they had a display in the window. They had a giant penis. And then next to it, they had a really detailed hairy vagina in the front window. Welcome to Los Angeles, Mr. Kinsey. I know. I said to my dad, I was like, oh, how is your walk? He was like, you guys got some interesting cakes. I'm like, cakes, what are you talking about? And then I remembered. I was like, oh, yeah. Dad, if you need a neurotic cake, I know where to send you. All right. Let's get back to your Phyllis one-liners. Let's get back. Okay. Number three, we have a gym at home. It's called the
早晨。他起得真早。比如，早上 5 点。他就出门了。穿戴整齐。去散步。我把那家色情蛋糕店的事给忘得精光。他们在橱窗里摆了个展示。他们有一个巨大的阴茎。然后旁边，在正面的橱窗里还有一个非常详细的有毛的阴道。欢迎来到洛杉矶，金西先生。我知道。我对爸爸说，我问，哦，你散步怎么样？他说，你们这儿有些挺有意思的蛋糕。我说，蛋糕，你在说什么呢？然后我想起来了。我说，哦，对。爸，如果你需要色情蛋糕，我知道该把你送到哪儿去。好啦。让我们回到你的菲莉丝金句上来。我们回去吧。好的。第三名，我们家里有个健身房。它叫
bedroom. Oh, yeah. And then Sam, the next one is your clip that people probably like her jugs. Excellent. Next one is, I never had an orgasm until I was 42. And then when I did, it lasted until I was 44. 43 was just, ah, I got nothing done. Which made it into the show, Bible. Next one, Bob Vance bought this perfume for me in Metropolitan Orlando. It's made from real pine. That was another scene I almost picked as my favorite Phyllis moment.
卧室。哦，对。然后，萨姆，下一条就是你的那个片段，大家可能很喜欢她的胸。太棒了。下一条是，我直到 42 岁才有过高潮。然后当我有的时候，一直持续到 44 岁。43 岁简直是，啊，我什么都没干成。这一句甚至被收录进了节目圣经。下一条，鲍勃·凡斯在奥兰多都会区给我买了这个香水。它是用真正的松木制成的。那是另一个我差点选为我最喜欢的菲莉丝时刻的场景。
I love how, like, offended she was about, it was Karen that didn't like her perfume, right? Well, Karen is like smelling something, and she's like, what is that? What smell? What is that? And Phyllis is like, oh, I'll help you find it. And she comes over to her desk. And then Karen's like, oh, my God, sorry. I think I'm just allergic to your perfume. Yeah. And Phyllis is pissed. I have that clip, by the way, if you want it. Oh, let's hear it. Let's hear it. What's that smell? What smell? Must be a air freshener plugged in somewhere. It sounds like a funeral home. Oh, I'll help you find it. Oh, you know, never, never mind. What is it? I think I'm just allergic to your perfume.
我太喜欢她那种被冒犯的感觉了，不喜欢她香水的那个人是凯伦吧？好吧，凯伦当时在闻什么东西，她说，那是什么味道？什么味道？那是什么？菲莉丝就说，哦，我来帮妳找。然后她走到凯伦的桌子旁。接着凯伦说，哦，天哪，对不起。我想我只是对你的香水过敏。是的。然后菲莉丝气炸了。顺便说一句，如果你想要的话，我手里有那个片段。哦，我们听听看。听听看。那是什么味道？什么味道？肯定有什么地方插了空气清新剂。这听起来像个殡仪馆。哦，我来帮妳找。哦，你懂得，没，没关系。那是什么？我想我只是对你的香水过敏。
My perfume? It's just my crazy nose. I've used to different smells. Bob Vance bought this perfume for me in Metropolitan Orlando. It's made from Real Pine. Who's Bob Vance? You have a lot to learn about this town, sweetie. That's great tag.
我的香水？只是我这怪鼻子。我习惯了不同的气味。鲍勃·凡斯在奥兰多都会区给我买了这个香水。它是用真正的松木制成的。谁是鲍勃·凡斯？关于这个小镇，你还有很多要学的呢，亲爱的。这真是个绝妙的收尾。
It's so great. All right. Next one is, I'm glad Michael's getting help. He has a lot of issues, and he's stupid. It made me loud, hell loud. I forgot it. It did me too. Okay. Next one, this isn't your grandmother's Christmas party. She has a lot of swagger. She does. The next one tugged at my heart strength. Phyllis says, I just think we all deserve to be with someone who wants to be with us. Is that good? Good little nugget of wisdom there. And lastly, my favorite Phyllis quote is one that's an inside joke with my friends. Jenna, you know this one about me. I guess whenever it rains, I do say the plants are going to be so happy. And I just wanted to hear all of Phyllis's quotes about rain. Here they are.
太棒了。好的。下一条是，我很高兴迈克尔在接受治疗。他有很多问题，而且他很蠢。这句话让我大声笑了出来。我都忘了。我也是。好的。下一条，这可不是你奶奶的圣诞派对。她很有气场。她确实有。下一条直击我的心灵深处。菲莉丝说，我只是觉得我们所有人都值得和一个想和我们在一起的人在一起。很棒吧？里面蕴含着一点智慧的小精髓。最后，我最喜欢的菲莉丝金句是一个我和朋友们之间的内部梗。珍娜，你知道我说的这个。我猜每当下雨时，我都会说“植物们会非常高兴的”。我只是想听听菲莉丝所有关于下雨的金句。都在这儿了。
Wow, it is raining cats and dogs out there. Holy, holy. Phyllis says the same 12 cliches every time it rains. So, I promised everyone that if she says them all by noon today, I will send out for hot chocolates. So how's the drive in? Nobody knows how to drive in the rain. You don't say? Yeah. You know, the roads are actually the slickest in the first half hour.
哇，外面正下着倾盆大雨呢。天哪，天哪。每次下雨，菲莉丝都会说同样的 12 个陈词滥调。所以，我向大家保证，如果她今天中午之前把这些全说了，我就会叫人买热巧克力送来。那么，开车来上班怎么样？根本没人懂得在雨天开车。不是吗？对啊。你知道的，雨刚下的前半小时路面其实是最滑的。
The plants are going to love this. Yeah. I actually sleep better when it's raining. Tell me about it. Time's almost up. How many are left? Just one. This weather makes me want to stay at home curled up with a good book.
植物们会喜欢这个的。对。我其实在下雨天睡得更好。可不是嘛。时间快到了。还剩几个？只有一个。这天气让我真想待在家里，蜷缩起来看一本好书。
Phyllis, this rain, does it make you want to be doing something? What do you mean? You know, like, aren't some things just so nice and cozy in the rain? Hey, come on. Lots of things are cozy in the rain. And that's noon, exactly. I mean, normally the rain would make me want to stay at home curled up with a good book, but everybody's being so nice to me today.
菲莉丝，这雨，它让你想做点什么吗？你什么意思？你知道的，就像，难道有些事情在雨里不是很美好、很温馨吗？嘿，得了吧。下雨天温馨的事可多着呢。正好到中午，分秒不差。我的意思是，通常下雨会让我想待在家里蜷缩着看一本好书，但今天每个人对我都很友好。
I'm really happy being here. Cute. So cute. I just love it. I loved visiting those one-liners, Angela. You know, we got a lot of mail about the evolution of Phyllis' character and how she is sort of like soft-spoken, yet also confident. especially after her relationship with Bob starts. And as you have shown, she gets some zingers in there. Yeah. And, you know, she even made it onto some office villain lists because of her snark.
我呆在这里真的很开心。真可爱。太可爱了。我太喜欢了。安吉拉，回顾那些金句真是太棒了。你知道的，我们收到了很多关于菲莉丝这个角色的演变以及她如何变得既轻声细语又自信的信件。特别是跟鲍勃确立关系之后。正如你所展示的那样，她确实在其中贡献了不少犀利的俏皮话。是的。而且，你知道的，因为她的刻薄，她甚至还上了某些《办公室》恶人榜。
Oh, yeah. Yes, I was excited to ask Phyllis about this. But first, let's get into my area of interest, which is fan theories explored. Oh, I love a fan theory. What you got? So the sexual harassment episode in season two created two big mysteries about Phyllis. We got tons of mail about both of these things. So the first thing we learned about Phyllis in this episode was that she had a one-night stand with someone in the office. And fans have been trying to figure out who it could be. This is when, you know, there's that scene where we're told you have to disclose office relationships. And Phyllis says even one-night stands.
哦，对。是的，我很高兴问菲利斯关于这件事。但首先，让我们进入我感兴趣的领域，也就是探讨粉丝理论。哦，我太喜欢粉丝理论了。你有什么料？所以，第二季的“性骚扰”那一集制造了关于菲利斯的两个巨大谜团。我们收到了关于这两件事的大量信件。我们在这一集中关于菲利斯的第一个发现是，她和办公室里的某个人有过一夜情。粉丝们一直在试图弄清楚那会是谁。这是在，你知道的，有那个场景，我们被告知你必须披露办公室恋情。菲利斯说哪怕是一夜情也算。
Yes. A lot of people have wondered if it was Stanley Hudson. But in our All About Stanley episode, you found that deleted scene that totally debunked that theory. Yes, thank you, Dave Rogers. Well, we got mail about a new theory of who it could be. Who? Christina G. from Portugal said, could Todd Packer be a one-night stand? Oh, for sure.
是的。很多人想知道那是不是斯坦利·哈德逊。但在我们的“走近斯坦利”那一集里，你找到了那段完全驳斥了这个理论的删减片段。是的，谢谢你，戴夫·罗杰斯。好吧，我们收到了关于那个人到底是谁的新理论的来信。是谁？来自葡萄牙的克里斯蒂娜·G说，托德·帕克会不会是一夜情对象？哦，绝对有可能。
In the sexual harassment episode, Michael said that back in the day, Todd Packer, quote, as a joke, slept with every woman in the office. And in the episode where Ed Trucks, Kappa was detated from his head, we find out that at some point, Ed Truck was Phyllis's boss as well, which means Phyllis was already working at Dunder Mifflin when Michael was a salesman and during those legendary days with Packer. When they would party and they all had mullets. Yeah. And when Todd Packer slept with every woman in the office. Also, Coru from Brazil said, hey, ladies, since I'm not. I was curious to know who Phyllis's one-night stand was. I ended up doing some research, and I think that person might be Todd Packer. Meredith confirms that she and Todd Packer
在“性骚扰”那一集中，迈克尔说过去托德·帕克，引用原话，“作为开玩笑，睡遍了办公室里的每一个女人”。而在埃德·特克的头和身体分家的那一集里，我们发现埃德·特克在某个时候也是菲利斯的老板，这意味着当迈克尔还是个推销员以及在帕克那些传奇的日子里，菲利斯就已经在邓德米夫林工作了。当时他们经常聚会，而且都留着鲻鱼头。是的。当时托德·帕克睡遍了办公室里的每一个女人。还有，来自巴西的科鲁说，嘿，女士们，既然我不是，我很想知道菲利斯的一夜情对象是谁。我最后做了一些研究，我觉得那个人可能是托德·帕克。梅雷迪思证实她和托德·帕克
did have sex in the past, and the only female who has worked in the office longer than Meredith and still works there is Phyllis. People said, please discuss. I mean, I totally buy this, just because of those early-day parties. Yeah. Well, there were a couple of other names that got tossed around. They were Devin, Ed truck. Ed truck, I buy. And Creed. But it almost always comes back to Todd Packer, and here is why. People noted that Phyllis said she didn't have her first orgasm until she was 42. If we look at sort of the timeline of the office and we assume she was 40 when filming started, Bob Vance was introduced as her boyfriend in season two. So it kind of lines up that maybe she had her first orgasm with Bob Vance.
过去确实发生过性关系，而办公室里工作时间比梅雷迪思长且现在还在那里工作的唯一的女性就是菲利斯。人们说，请讨论一下。我的意思是，我完全相信这一点，就因为那些早期的聚会。是的。好吧，还有另外几个被提及的名字。他们是德文，埃德·特克。埃德·特克，我信。还有克里德。但几乎总是绕回托德·帕克，原因如下。人们注意到菲利斯说过她在42岁之前都没有过第一次高潮。如果我们看一下办公室的时间线，并且假设她开始拍摄时40岁，鲍勃·万斯在第二季中作为她的男友被引入。所以这在某种程度上吻合，也许她是在和鲍勃·万斯在一起时有了第一次高潮。
So fans have pointed out that Creed could not have been her one-night stand because, quote, he definitely knows how to please a woman. And this brings people back to Packer since, quote, he definitely has never pleased a woman. So I guess we're down to Todd Packer or Ed Truck. There is Devin, I guess, as well. Devin, I guess. I mean, just for the story of Bob and Phyllis, it does make sense, especially as, you know, the scene Cassie pointed out where they get it on in the bathroom. Yeah.
因此粉丝们指出，克里德不可能是一夜情对象，因为，引用原话，“他绝对知道如何取悦女人”。这又把人们带回了帕克，因为，引用原话，“他绝对从没取悦过女人”。所以我想我们只能在托德·帕克或埃德·特克之间选了。我想还有一个德文。德文，我想吧。我的意思是，单就鲍勃和菲利斯的故事而言，这确实说得通，特别是正如，你知道的，凯西指出的他们在浴室里亲热的那个场景。是的。
And she says the gym is the bedroom. It does make sense to me that her first orgasm was with Bob, and that's why she's always down to miss around. I mean, I think this was a huge, like, sexual awakening for her. Yes. getting married to Bob, having a partner who was interested in pleasuring her. It's never too late. It's definitely never too late. Yeah.
她说健身房就是卧室。对我来说，这确实说得通，她的第一次高潮是和鲍勃在一起的，这就是为什么她总是愿意到处乱搞。我的意思是，我认为这对她来说是一次巨大的，类似于性觉醒的经历。是的。和鲍勃结婚，有一个对取悦她感兴趣的伴侣。这永远不会太迟。这绝对永远不会太迟。是的。
Well, I checked AI. Oh, no. What did AI say? What did AI say? AI said no. Phyllis did not have a one-night stand with Todd Packer on the office. AI doesn't know. Well, AI said while Michael does jokingly suggest that Packer slept with everyone in the office, including Phyllis, this is not a confirmed event in the show.
好吧，我问了人工智能。哦，不。人工智能说什么了？人工智能说什么了？人工智能说没有。菲利斯没有和托德·帕克在办公室发生过一夜情。人工智能根本不懂。好吧，人工智能说虽然迈克尔确实开玩笑地暗示帕克睡了办公室里的每个人，包括菲利斯，但这并不是剧中得到证实的事情。
There is no evidence in the show to support the claim that Phyllis had a one-night stand with Packer. And the idea that Phyllis had a one-night stand with Packer is likely a misunderstanding or a joke made by Michael, who is known for his exaggerated and often inaccurate stories. I feel like you just had a debate, like is Toby the Scranton Strangler, but you had it with AI. I did. All right. The other thing that we find out in this episode, sexual harassment, is that she and Michael are the, the same age because it is revealed that they were in the same class in high school. However, many people wrote in with the theory that Michael is actually older than Phyllis,
剧中没有任何证据支持菲利斯和帕克有过一夜情的说法。而菲利斯和帕克有过一夜情的想法很可能是一个误解，或者是迈克尔开的一个玩笑，他以夸大其词且经常不准确的故事而闻名。我觉得你们刚才进行了一场辩论，就像“托比是斯克兰顿扼喉杀手吗”，但你是在和人工智能辩论。我是。好吧。我们在“性骚扰”这一集中发现的另一件事是，她和迈克尔是，是同龄人，因为据透露他们在高中时是同一个班的。然而，很多人写信提出这样一个理论，即迈克尔实际上比菲利斯年龄大，
and they say that the evidence for this is Michael's talking head from season four, Dunder Mifflin Infinity, Part 2. Let's listen. Ever since I was a kid, people have been telling me that I can't do things. You can't be on the team. you can't move on to second grade. Well, now they're telling me that I can't win back clients using old-fashioned business methods. We'll see about that. And FYI, I eventually ate second grade, and I was the biggest kid in class.
他们说这背后的证据是迈克尔在第四季“邓德米夫林无限公司，第二部分”中的独白。我们来听听。从小到大，人们一直告诉我，有些事我做不到。你不能加入球队。你不能升入二年级。好吧，现在他们告诉我，我不能用老式的商业方法赢得客户。我们走着瞧。顺便说一句，我最终搞定了二年级，而且我是班里最大的孩子。
So here's the thing. If Michael was held back in second grade, he says eventually ace second grade. Did he repeat it once? Did he repeat it twice? Oh, my goodness. That would mean that if he and Phyllis were in the same. class in high school, Michael is actually one or two years older than everybody in the class. Provided Phyllis wasn't held back as well. No evidence that she was. So maybe Phyllis is
所以情况是这样的。如果迈克尔留级读了二年级，他说最终搞定了二年级。他是重复了一次吗？他是重复了两次吗？哦，天哪。那将意味着，如果他和菲利斯在高中时是同一个，班级，迈克尔实际上比班里的每个人都大一到两岁。前提是菲利斯没有留级。没有证据表明她留级了。所以也许菲利斯
younger than Michael. I mean, that would definitely make Michael crazy. Yeah. All right. Finally, this is not a fan theory, just a fan letter that led me to a nugget that I have to share because it was so Sweet. Ronica from Jacksonville, Florida, said, in the superfan episode for Goodbye Toby, there's a scene that's been added with Bob Vance giving Phyllis additional money for the parking lot extravaganza. Lady, you know, this is the episode Goodbye Toby, where Phyllis is put in charge of planning this big goodbye party, but she's been given a tiny budget. She goes out to the parking lot with Bob Vance. You have to hear it. And if the food stations are here and here
比迈克尔年轻。我的意思是，那绝对会把迈克尔逼疯。是的。好吧。最后，这不是一个粉丝理论，而只是一封粉丝来信，它引导我发现了一个我必须分享的有趣花絮，因为它太甜蜜了。来自佛罗里达州杰克逊维尔的罗尼卡说，在“告别托比”的超长粉丝版中，有一个新增的场景，鲍勃·万斯给菲利斯额外的钱来筹办停车场盛会。女士们，你们知道，这就是“告别托比”那一集，菲利斯负责策划这个盛大的告别派对，但她只拿到了微薄的预算。她和鲍勃·万斯一起走到停车场。你们必须听听这个。如果餐台在这里和这里
no here and here drinks here then people can mingle but then where would the band go hmm what about there oh no bob
不，在这里和这里，饮料在这里，然后人们可以社交，但是乐队会去哪里呢？嗯，那个地方怎么样？哦，不，鲍勃
I don't know it's times like these I wish my mother were with me right now she'd show me what to do that's stupid she's not here she's at water aerobics for the next 45 minutes Phyllis, is that going to be enough food?
我不知道，每当这个时候我都希望我妈妈现在能陪在我身边，她会告诉我该怎么做。真蠢，她不在这。她在接下来的45分钟里在上水中操课。菲利斯，食物够吗？
That's all I have in the budget. Is it just a matter of money? Oh, bye. Anything for my lovely. What would I do without you? I hope you never have to find out. See you at the point. Isn't that so sweet?
这就是我预算里所有的钱了。这只是钱的问题吗？哦，再见。为了我的挚爱，我什么都愿意做。没有你我该怎么办。我希望你永远都不用去发现。一会见。是不是太甜了？
It's so sweet. And also, I was about to get sad about her mom, but then we find out she's at water aerobics. I know. in the writing. That whole thing, it takes so many fun twists and turns. Like you just don't know where it's going. And I love how that scene just ends with this genuine, just love and affection between her and Bob fans. Yeah. I loved it. Those are great. I love your fan theories. Thank you. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? Because when we come back, we're going to dive into your questions. And Phyllis gives us such good nuggets.
太甜了。而且，我正准备为她的妈妈感到难过，但接着我们发现她在上水中操课。我知道。剧本写得真妙。整段剧情，它有那么多有趣的反转。就像你根本不知道它会走向何方。我喜欢那个场景的结尾，只有鲍勃·万斯和她之间那种真挚的、纯粹的爱与温情。是的。我太喜欢了。这些都太棒了。我喜欢你们的粉丝理论。谢谢。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下？因为当我们回来时，我们将深入探讨你们的问题。而菲利斯给我们提供了这么多好料。
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, sometimes we turn to some funny places for support. Maybe a hairdresser, a barista, maybe a random stranger in the bathroom for life advice. But not everyone is a therapist. You can find your right match with BetterHelp. BetterHelp therapists are clinically trained and credentialed. They work according to a strict code of conduct and are fully licensed in the use. And BetterHelp does the initial matching work for you, so you can focus on your therapy goals.
本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，有时我们会去一些奇怪的地方寻求支持。也许是理发师，咖啡师，也许是浴室里的某个陌生人来寻求人生建议。但并不是每个人都是治疗师。你可以在 BetterHelp 找到真正适合你的匹配。BetterHelp 的治疗师都经过临床培训并持有证书。他们遵循严格的行为准则，并且拥有完全的执照。BetterHelp 会为你完成最初的匹配工作，这样你就可以专注于你的治疗目标。
You'll get a short questionnaire that helps identify your needs and preferences, and then they will match you with a licensed therapist. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Find the one with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month. month at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelphelp.com slash office ladies. With Amex Platinum, access to exclusive Amex presale tickets can score
你会得到一份简短的问卷，帮助确定你的需求和偏好，然后他们会为你匹配一位有执照的治疗师。作为全球最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp 可以为你提供拥有各种专业知识的心理健康专业人士。来 BetterHelp 寻找适合的那个人吧。我们的听众在 betterhelp.com 栏目 office ladies 的第一个月可以享受 9 折优惠。网址是 BetterHelphelp.com 栏目 office ladies。使用美国运通白金卡，获得独家美国运通预售门票，可以为你赢得一个
you a spot track side. So being a fan for life turns into the trip of a lifetime. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Pre-sale tickets for future events subject to availability and vary by race. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at mx.ca.com. You can get protein at home or a protein latte at Tim's. No powders, no blenders, no shakers. Starting at 17 grams per medium latte, Tim's new protein lattes, protein without all the work, at participating restaurants in Canada. We are back and it's time to jump into our mailbag for all about Phyllis. Now, unfortunately, Phyllis couldn't join us today, but she sent in some audio clips and she sent back some responses to your questions. So, Let's get started.
赛道旁的位置。因此，终身粉丝可以变成一生难忘的旅行。这就是美国运通强大的后盾。未来活动的预售票视供应情况而定，并因比赛而异。适用条款和条件。请在 mx.ca.com 了解更多信息。你可以在家里享用蛋白质，或者在 Tim's 享用蛋白质拿铁。没有粉末，没有搅拌机，没有摇摇杯。中杯拿铁起步17克蛋白质，Tim's 的全新蛋白质拿铁，无需费力即可补充蛋白质，加拿大参与活动的餐厅均有售。我们回来啦，是时候打开我们的信箱，聊聊所有关于菲利斯的内容了。现在，不幸的是，菲利斯今天没能加入我们，但她发来了一些音频剪辑，并对你们的问题做出了回应。那么，让我们开始吧。
Let's get started. Big hugs for Phyllis in St. Louis. Hi, Phyllis. Hi, Phyllis. All right. So we've shared on the podcast before, and I think people know this, Phyllis was cast on the show because she was working as a casting associate for Allison Jones. Yes. She read with us during our auditions, and director Ken Koppas suggested, you know what, she should have a part in the pilot.
让我们开始吧。给圣路易斯的菲利斯一个大大的拥抱。嗨，菲利斯。嗨，菲利斯。好的。所以我们之前在播客中分享过，我想大家也都知道，菲利斯被选中出演这部剧是因为她当时在为艾莉森·琼斯担任选角助理。是的。她在我们的试镜期间和我们对词，导演肯·科普斯建议说，你知道吗，她应该在试播集中演个角色。
But we wanted to revisit this because we got this great question from Gracie in Springville, Utah. Grace says, how did Phyllis Smith end up in Los Angeles? And how did she come to work with Allison Jones as a casting associate? I mean, Jenna and I were so curious because we realize we know how she got her role in the office, but we don't know how she ended up in Los Angeles. Or how she ended up working with Allison. That's right. Well, Phyllis sent us in a clip answering your question, Grace, and here it is. Well, I was on the road in a vaudeville burles show. I was doing like show dancing, the Charleston, the original can-can from the Moulin Rouge. We did not strip.
但我们想重新温习这一点，因为我们收到了来自犹他州斯普林维尔的格雷西提出的这个棒极了的问题。格雷斯问，菲利斯·史密斯是怎么到洛杉矶的？她又是怎么开始和艾莉森·琼斯一起担任选角助理的？我的意思是，珍娜和我非常好奇，因为我们意识到我们知道她是如何在办公室里获得这个角色的，但我们不知道她是怎么去到洛杉矶的。或者她是怎么开始和艾莉森一起工作的。没错。好吧，菲利斯发给我们一段剪辑来回答你的问题，格雷斯，内容是这样的。好吧，我当时在巡回演出，参加一个杂耍滑稽秀。我做的是那种歌舞表演，查尔斯顿舞，红磨坊的原创康康舞。我们没有脱衣。
We had strategically placed feathers. It was a lot of fun. I worked with Will Be Able and his show called Baggy Pants. And then I continued in another vaudeville show working with the Mercer brothers, Bud and Jim Mercer. and combined with Baggy Pants and Bud and Jim show called Giggles Gullor, I was on the road about six or seven years. And then the Mercer Brothers and I, we decided to take the show to California to revamp the show,
我们身上战略性地贴着羽毛。这太有趣了。我和威尔·贝布尔合作过，他的节目叫《宽松裤》。然后我在另一个杂耍秀里继续工作，和莫瑟兄弟，巴德和吉姆·莫瑟合作。结合了《宽松裤》和巴德与吉姆的名为《咯咯笑》的节目，我在路上巡演了大约六七年。然后莫瑟兄弟和我，我们决定把这个节目带到加利福尼亚去改版，
and the Mercer Brothers lived in California, so that's why we decided to take the show to California. And while we were in the throes of revamping the show, we ended up getting a job in Long Beach at Shoreline Village, and the show was called The Captain's Crew Review. I think the sign is still up there on the boardwalk, if you ever get down that way. And we did three shows on Saturday, three on Sunday, and we did that for an entire season. Then I injured my knee doing a jump split at the end of the Can Can, and so that kind of ended my
而莫瑟兄弟住在加利福尼亚，这就是为什么我们决定把这个节目带到加利福尼亚。正当我们忙于改版这个节目的时候，我们最终在长滩的海岸线村找到了一份工作，这个节目叫做《船长船员秀》。如果你去过那边的话，我想那个招牌现在还挂在木板路上。我们周六演三场，周日演三场，我们这样演了一整季。然后我在康康舞结束时做一个跳跃劈叉时弄伤了膝盖，所以这差不多就结束了我的
dancing career. I ended up becoming a receptionist at an aerospace defense company. And while I was working there, I got a call to actually go on an audition for a mousy woman. I went in. I did not get the role because it wasn't mousy enough. But during that audition, I told the casting director, I think I might be good in casting. And then a little while later, I got a call to be her casting coordinator at the Edwards Billet Production Company. They did things like the court shows, like Superior Court and other shows. And I met a gentleman by the name of Alan Hockberg, and we were both working in the casting department at Edwards Billet Productions. And Alan ended up working as the casting director on Dr. Quinn Medicine Woman. And he asked me to be his
舞蹈生涯。我最终成为了一家航空航天国防公司的前台接待员。在我工作期间，我接到一个电话，去为一个唯唯诺诺的女人试镜。我去了。我没有得到这个角色，因为我不够唯唯诺诺。但在那次试镜中，我告诉选角导演，我觉得我可能很适合做选角工作。然后过了一会儿，我接到一个电话，去爱德华兹·比列特制作公司做她的选角协调员。他们制作诸如法庭秀之类的节目，比如《高级法院》和其他节目。我遇到了一位名叫艾伦·霍克伯格的先生，我们当时都在爱德华兹·比列特制作公司的选角部门工作。艾伦最终在《吉尔医生》中担任选角导演，他邀请我做他在
associate with him on Dr. Quinn. We did Dr. Quinn for the run of the show, and when it ended, I walked out of the casting office, and I walked across the hall to another casting director's office, and I said, hey, guys, see y'all later. This is my last day with Alan Hockberg, and if you know of anyone that needs a casting associate, I'm available. and they said, you know, Allison Jones needs an associate. So they gave me her number, and I called her, had an interview with her,
$《吉尔医生》中的助理。我们做《吉尔医生》一直做到这部剧结束，当它结束时，我走出了选角办公室，走到大厅对面另一个选角导演的办公室，我说，嘿，伙计们，回见。这是我和艾伦·霍克伯格在一起的最后一天，如果你们知道谁需要选角助理，我有空。他们说，你知道艾莉森·琼斯需要一个助理。所以他们给了我她的电话号码，我给她打了电话，和她进行了面试，
and I started work that following Monday. And that's how I ended up at Allison Jones. So it was kind of a meant to be. I went out the door of one casting office and into another casting office. So that's how I came to California. I mean, a jump split? That sounds very difficult. You do jump splits on the trampoline. I mean, if I don't land in the splits, though, right? Oh, yes. I do. Right. Yeah, like a toe touch, but I'm not landing. Yeah. I land on my feet. Well, that just goes to show you that one door closes, another one opens, and Phyllis walked through it and ended up walking her way onto our show.
我在接下来的周一就开始工作了。这就是我最后来到艾莉森·琼斯那里的过程。所以这有点像是命中注定。我走出一个选角办公室的门，又走进了另一个选角办公室的门。这就是我来到加利福尼亚的方式。我的意思是，跳跃劈叉？听起来非常困难。你在蹦床上有过跳跃劈叉。我的意思是，如果我劈叉时没有落地，对吧？哦，是的。我有。对。是的，就像触趾跳，但我没有落地。是的。我是用双脚着地的。好吧，这恰恰向你证明，一扇门关上了，另一扇门就会打开，菲利斯走了过去，最终走进了我们的节目。
That's right. I do just love her sort of just like. like, get out there, put yourself out there, just walked across the hall, said, hey, I'm available for a job. Phyllis talked a little bit about her dancing in that audio clip, and we got this fan question from Marina M in Melbourne, Australia, who said, I love watching Phyllis dance and the joy she has in her movement. Could Phyllis give us a little rundown of her dancing background? Well, Marina, Phyllis told us that she started dancing at seven years old, and the majority of her training was in St. Louis. with Marjorie Mendelea. Was Marjorie sort of a big deal in St. Louis for dancing? I don't know Marjorie.
没错。我就是喜欢她那种，就是，走出去，勇敢展现自我，直接走到大厅说，嘿，我有空可以工作。菲利斯在那个音频片段里谈到了她的一些舞蹈经历，我们收到了来自澳大利亚墨尔本的玛丽娜·M的粉丝提问，她说，我喜欢看菲利斯跳舞以及她在动作中表现出的快乐。菲利斯能跟我们简单聊聊她的舞蹈背景吗？好的，玛丽娜，菲利斯告诉我们她七岁开始跳舞，她的训练大部分是在圣路易斯跟着马乔里·门德利亚进行的。马乔里在圣路易斯的舞蹈界算是个大人物吗？我不知道马乔里是谁。
I studied at Kripinski's. Oh. And it has been passed down through three generations now, from Lillian Kripinski to Mark Kripinski to his daughter. I don't know her name. She was a little girl when I was dancing because I studied mostly under Mark. But I started with Lillian. Now this is becoming about my dance background.
我曾在克里宾斯基家学习过。哦。而且这项技艺已经代代相传了三代人，从莉莲·克里宾斯基到马克·克里宾斯基，再到他的女儿。我不记得她叫什么名字了。我跳舞时她还是个小女孩，因为我主要跟马克学习。但我最初是跟着莉莲学的。现在这倒成我的舞蹈背景专访了。
Everyone, sorry for that. But Lillian Kripinski, for ballet class, she used to walk around with a cane and she would whop the floor right next to us, like if our toes weren't pointed correctly or if our turnout wasn't correct. Yeah. Oh, I'd be out. Well, she retired and Mark took over. But, yeah, so I studied at Kripenskys.
各位，不好意思啊。不过莉莲·克里宾斯基上芭蕾课时，她总是拿着一根手杖到处走，如果我们的脚尖没有绷直或者外开动作不标准，她就会拿手杖狠狠敲打我们身旁的地面。天哪。哦，那我肯定早就被淘汰了。不过，她退休后马克接手了。但是，对，所以我是在克里宾斯基那里学的。
Well, I'm just sort of getting a vibe here from my St. Louis gals that dances kind of got a real community there. I think there is a big dance community in St. Louis. Okay. So back to Phyllis. Yes. She said she took ballet tap and jazz. She also danced in two ballet companies, the St. Louis Civic Ballet and the St. Louis Dance Theater. Wow. She did point. And she also studied at Kansas City University and Tulsa University in the summer. She said they had these six-week intensified workshops that she did for like three or four different summers. So a lot of dance training. This is when I wish we could just take a minute and just, like, time travel and meet Phyllis back then and, like, see her on stage. Wouldn't that be so fun? Yeah. Well, Phyllis also said she ended up working at J.C. Pennies, and she would teach dancing at night and take lessons at night. And then she ended up eventually going to Washington University to get her certificate to teach modern dance. I didn't
好吧，从我的圣路易斯老乡们身上我能感觉到，那里的舞蹈似乎有着很浓厚的社区氛围。我认为圣路易斯确实有一个很大的舞蹈社区。好的。那么回到菲利斯。是的。她说她学过芭蕾、踢踏和爵士。她还在两家芭蕾舞团跳过舞，分别是圣路易斯市民芭蕾舞团和圣路易斯舞蹈剧院。哇。她确实很专业。她还在夏天去堪萨斯大学和塔尔萨大学学习过。她说她们有那种持续六周的强化工作坊，她连续三四年夏天都参加了。所以她受过大量的舞蹈训练。这时候我真希望我们能花上一分钟，时光倒流回到过去，去见见当年的菲利斯，在舞台上看看她。那该多有趣啊？是的。嗯，菲利斯还说她最后去了J.C.潘尼百货工作，她晚上教跳舞，晚上还上课。然后她最终去了圣路易斯华盛顿大学取得了现代舞教学证书。我当时
know any of this. Me either. Unfortunately, she didn't end up getting her certificate. I guess she missed it by one or two hours. But she took a ton of dance class. And as Phyllis shared with us, she also ended up dancing in a jazz company in San Diego one summer. And then that got her into the vaudeville burlesque show scene. And she was on the road for about six or seven years doing that show. I guess until the jump split. I mean, yeah, that is a long time. And Phyllis said, you know, she always knew she wanted to be a dancer.
一点都不知道这事。我也不知道。遗憾的是，她最终没有拿到证书。我猜她就差了一两个小时。不过她上了大量的舞蹈课。正如菲利斯跟我们分享的，有一年夏天她还在圣地亚哥的一家爵士舞团跳过舞。这之后她进入了杂耍滑稽秀的圈子。她跟着那个巡演节目在路上跑了大约六七年。我想直到跳劈叉为止吧。我是说，对，那真的很长时间。菲利斯说，你知道的，她一直都知道自己想成为一名舞者。
I love that. That was her first love. Her first love. And she did get to shimmy and dance on the office. Well, it shows. that she always wanted to be a dancer because it brought out a joy in her every time she did it. Mm-hmm. Kick-ball change.
我太喜欢这个了。那是她的初恋。她的初恋。而且她确实得以在办公室里扭动身姿、翩翩起舞。嗯，这说明她一直想当舞者，因为每次跳舞都会带给她发自内心的快乐。嗯哼。踢腿球转换。
Kick-ball change, lady. Potaboo-ray. Okay, so now that we got the Phyllis Smith backstory, a lot of you wrote in asking if Phyllis created a backstory for the character of Phyllis, and if so, could we share some of the details? Well, we asked Phyllis, and here's what she said. she said, to be very honest, I was so new as an actor that I generally concentrated on trying to do the words of the script to be as authentic as I could be. I really didn't know to create a backstory. So I think my character developed by how the writer saw my personality. We had multiple writers on the show, and various writers would see Phyllis different ways.
踢腿球转换，女士。法式小碎步。好了，既然我们已经了解了菲利斯·史密斯的背景故事，你们很多人写信问，菲利斯有没有为“菲利斯”这个角色创作过背景故事，如果有的话，我们能不能分享一些细节？好吧，我们问了菲利斯，她是这么说的。她说，老实说，我作为一名演员实在太新了，我当时基本上只专注于努力把剧本的台词说好，尽可能表现得真实。我当时真的不知道还要去创作一个背景故事。所以我认为我的角色是通过编剧们如何看待我的个性来发展的。我们在剧中有好几位编剧，不同的编剧对菲利斯的看法也各不相同。
Phyllis said some of the writers would see her as shy, others saw her as sassy. So she basically just concentrated on the written word. And that's what brought authenticity to her performance. I love that. It sort of reminds me when we spoke to Lee and Jean, and they talked about how writers would write Michael in different ways. Yes. And I just think that's so smart of Phyllis to have observed that. Yeah. Phyllis went on to say, quote, I was new in that realm of the business, so I went out and bought books on improv because I had never really done improv before. And I knew that there had to be parameters and guidelines to go by. So I bought books to give me a little background on doing improv, but as far as my backstory, no, I did not create one. Yeah, but I mean, what she did
菲利斯说，有些编剧把她看作是害羞的，其他人则认为她很泼辣。所以她基本上只专注于剧本写出来的台词。正是这一点为她的表演带来了真实感。我太喜欢这个了。这让我想起我们跟李和让交谈的时候，他们谈到编剧们是如何以不同的方式来写迈克尔的。是的。而且我觉得菲利斯能观察到这一点真的非常聪明。是的。菲利斯接着说，引述一下，“我在这个行业的领域里还是个新人，所以我出去买了一些关于即兴表演的书，因为我以前真的没有做过即兴表演。而且我知道这里面必须有一些参数和指导方针可以遵循。所以我买了一些书来为我做即兴表演提供一点背景，但至于我的背景故事，不，我没有创造一个。”是的，不过我是说，她的做法
was just powerful in its own way because she just wanted to be authentic. Well, speaking of backstories, we got a fan mail flurry from people wanting to know more about her character's romance with Bob Vance, Vance for Fridgeration. Fan question from Michael C. in Staten Island, how How does Phyllis think her character met Bob Vance? I would have loved to see the courtship. Me too. Well, Phyllis sent us in a little clip about this, and here's what she said. In my own mind, I always thought it would be humorous if I helped Bob change the tire on his car.
以其独特的方式充满了力量，因为她只是想表现得真实。说到背景故事，我们收到了雪片般飞来的粉丝邮件，大家都想了解更多关于她的角色与鲍勃·范斯（范斯冷气公司）的浪漫史。来自史泰登岛的迈克尔·C的粉丝提问，菲利斯认为她的角色是如何遇到鲍勃·范斯的？我本很想看看他们的追求过程。我也是。好吧，菲利斯给我们发来了一小段关于这事的音频，她是这么说的。在我自己的心里，我一直觉得如果我帮鲍勃换汽车轮胎会很有趣。
You know, here is this really capable, strapping, strong man, and he needed help getting his flat tire on his car. changed in the parking lot at Dundermifflin. So I always thought it would be funny. So in my own mind, I helped Bob change the flat tire on his car. And as far as our romance, I always imagine that when Bob asked me to marry him, he rented out the booze cruise just for us. No one else was on it. He took me on the booze cruise, and it was just Bob Vance Vance refrigeration. And my and it was very romantic and really lovely. I'm not sure of the details, but you should ask Bob what his backstory was for us. He's really good at backstory, and I believe I read somewhere that he thought of Phyllis and Bob
你知道的，这里有一个非常有能力、身材魁梧、强壮的男人，而他在邓德米夫林的停车场里却需要有人帮忙换汽车爆胎。所以我一直觉得这会很搞笑。所以在我的想象中，我帮鲍勃换了汽车的爆胎。至于我们的浪漫史，我一直想象的是，当鲍勃向我求婚时，他把整个酒水游轮包下来只给我们俩。上面没有别人。他带我上了酒水游轮，船上只有范斯冷气公司的鲍勃·范斯。而且非常浪漫，真的十分可爱。我不清楚具体细节，但你应该去问问鲍勃，他为我们编的背景故事是什么。他在背景故事这方面真的很擅长，而且我记得我曾在某处读到过，他把菲利斯和鲍勃
as the girl that he cared so much for in high school. Evidently, there was someone in his life that he really cared for and he treated me as if I was that person that he cared so much for in high school. Also, his mother's name was Phyllis in real life and his father's name was Bob. So that was kind of an interesting thing. And I must say that Bob was and is such a professional. He was always so respectful and I really enjoyed our relationship of Phyllis and Bob Vance. He was wonderful to work with. And yeah, was just pretty cool. So that's Bob and Phyllis. You know, I feel like you saw that. You witnessed their mutual respect and affection for one another. Yeah. I love her proposal story. That he rented
看作是他在高中时极其珍视的那个女孩。显然，他生命中曾有过某个他非常在乎的人，而他对待我的方式就像我是那个他在高中时极其在乎的人一样。还有，他现实生活中的母亲叫菲利斯，父亲叫鲍勃。所以这真是一件挺有趣的事。我必须说，鲍勃过去是、现在也依然是如此专业。他总是那么尊重对方，我真的很享受我和鲍勃·范斯这段菲利斯与鲍勃的关系。和他一起工作太棒了。而且，是的，真的很酷。这就是鲍勃和菲利斯的故事。你知道，我觉得你看到了这一点。你见证了他们彼此尊重、互相关爱。是的。我太喜欢她的求婚故事了。他包下了
out the booze cruise. Yeah. Gosh, they did such a good job of chemistry casting on our show. Yeah, and some of this just came about. You know, it's not like Phyllis and Bob had ever auditioned together. It's true. Yeah. I mean, he came on as Bob Vance Vance Refrigeration before we ever knew that he was going to be paired up with Phyllis. Yeah. Wow. And how crazy is it that his parents were named Bob and Phyllis? I know. What are the chances? Well, we also got another letter from Megan S in San Diego, California. who said, why did Phyllis stay working after marrying Bob? It was established. He was a well-off business owner. I know show-wise, we needed her to stay, but I'm curious what Phyllis's reason was for not retiring because of Bob's wealth. Well, Megan, here's what Phyllis had to say.
酒水游轮。是的。天哪，我们在选角时的化学反应搭配得太棒了。是的，有些东西就是自然而然发生的。你知道的，并不是说菲利斯和鲍勃以前一起试镜过。确实如此。是的。我是说，在他加入成为范斯冷气公司的鲍勃·范斯之前，我们根本不知道他会和菲利斯配成一对。是的。哇，他的父母分别叫鲍勃和菲利斯，这简直太疯狂了。我懂。这几率有多大？好吧，我们还收到了来自加利福尼亚州圣地亚哥的梅根·S的另一封信，她问，为什么菲利斯在结婚后还要继续工作？剧情里已经设定好了。他是个生活优渥的企业主。我知道从剧情上来说，我们需要她留下来，但我很好奇菲利斯不因为鲍勃的财富而选择退休的原因是什么。好吧，梅根，菲利斯是这么说的。
Phyllis said, well, Phyllis enjoyed her job. She enjoyed the challenge of being a paper salesman, and she liked the company and the people and the friends that she had at Dunder Mifflin. And also, she didn't want to be fully dependent upon a man. She wanted to have her own source of income. I believe it. I do too. Also, you know, they met later in life. And she was a fully realized person.
菲利斯说，嗯，菲利斯很喜欢她的工作。她喜欢做纸品推销员的挑战，她喜欢邓德米夫林的公司、同事和她在那里的朋友。而且，她不想完全依附于一个男人。她想拥有自己的经济来源。我相信。我也这么觉得。而且，你知道的，他们是在人生较晚的时候相遇的。她是一个完全独立自主的个体。
You know, she didn't need Bob. She chose Bob. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Like that. All right. So you know how earlier we all shared our favorite phyllis moments? Yes.
你知道的，她不需要鲍勃。她选择的是鲍勃。哦，是的。是的。就是这样。好了，所以你们还记得之前我们都分享了自己最喜欢的菲利斯时刻吗？是的。
Well, we got this fan question from Sion J in London, England. Sion says, hey, Phyllis, you've got that perfect mix of sweet and sassy. What's your favorite Phyllis Byrne and how many of them were improvised? Well, I love a Phyllis Byrne, too, as you guys know. And Phyllis said many of her favorites were actually on the list of fan favorites that we shared. One of her absolute favorites was when Phyllis said, close your mouth, sweetie, you look like a trout. Mm-hmm. She also said she liked the one that we played, where she talks to Karen about her perfume that Bob Vance bought for her.
好吧，我们收到了来自英格兰伦敦的希昂·J的粉丝提问。希昂说，嘿，菲利斯，你身上有一种完美融合了甜美与泼辣的特质。你最喜欢菲利斯的哪次回怼？其中有多少是即兴发挥的？好吧，正如你们所知，我也很喜欢菲利斯的回怼。菲利斯说，她的许多最爱其实也在我们分享的粉丝最爱列表中。她绝对最喜欢的一幕是菲利斯说，“闭上你的嘴，亲爱的，你看起来像条虹鳟鱼。”嗯哼。她还说她喜欢我们播出的那一集，她在剧里跟凯伦谈论鲍勃·范斯给她买的香水。
She said, as Phyllis, I was very insulted by her not liking my perfume, and I like that burn as well. She did share that both of those were completely scripted, but she also said she did some improv with Rashida when they got their hair and makeup done, and they're all dressed up, you know, and they're in the car on the way to the companies in traveling salesmen. She said that she improvised a little bit how Phyllis Lappin thought Jim was hot. Okay. And she said afterwards Greg complimented her and said it was really funny, but it didn't make it in the episode. Well, I found it. Oh, really? Yes.
她说，作为菲利斯，我当时对凯伦不喜欢我的香水感到非常被冒犯，我也很喜欢那个回怼。她确实分享说，那两处完全是剧本写好的，但她也说，她和雷希达做完头发和妆容、打扮得漂漂亮亮在车上去旅行推销员拜访公司时，做了一些即兴发挥。她说，她即兴发挥了一点菲利斯·拉平觉得吉姆很性感的桥段。好吧。并且她事后说格雷格称赞了她，说那真的很好笑，但那个片段并没有剪进正片里。好吧，我找到了。哦，真的吗？是的。
It's in deleted scenes. By the way, deleted scenes on the DVD for the traveling salesman and the return, they're combined. It's like 22 minutes. Wow. So buckle in. There's a lot. But it's in there. And I think you should hear it.
它在删减片段里。顺便说一句，《旅行推销员》和《回归》的DVD删减片段是合并在一起的。大约有22分钟。哇。所以系好安全带吧。内容很多。但它就在里面。而且我觉得你们应该听听。
Jim is so. hot yeah i just every time he just like walks by i cannot help it stare at his bottom his butt really does he wear boxers or briefs or oh um or a g-string wow a g-string wow a g-string oh a g-string oh my gosh i know well we asked philis if there were any other memorable improvisations or unscripted involving Phyllis that stand out. And she said that in season one, in sexual harassment, when Michael's character goes over and starts, like, hugging her and messing up her hairdo, that was unscripted. I believe that. I watched that. She said she loves that moment. And it's also the first time she worked directly with Steve. Oh. Yeah. Yeah. And then, Lady, you know,
吉姆太性感了。是的，我每次只要看到他走过，我就忍不住盯着他的屁股看。他的屁股真的很……他穿的是平角裤还是三角裤，或者哦……还是丁字裤？哇，丁字裤。哇，丁字裤。哦，丁字裤。哦天哪。我知道。好吧，我们问菲利斯，是否还有其他令人难忘的即兴发挥，或者涉及菲利斯的非剧本台词让人印象深刻。她说在第一季的《性骚扰》中，当迈克尔的角色走过来开始拥抱她、弄乱她的发型时，那是没有剧本的。我相信这一点。我看过那个。她非常喜欢那个时刻。这也是她第一次直接与史蒂夫合作。哦。是的。是的。然后，女士，你知道的，
your favorite Phyllis moment was when she was Santa Claus. Yes, her talking head. Listen to what she said about that. She said that is one of her favorite talking heads because it wasn't written that she was supposed to cry. She said that she just started crying when she talked about how much she wanted to be Santa Claus because she felt how much Phyllis, the character, wanted to be Santa Claus. That is beautiful. I know. Phyllis, I'm telling you, man, what can't this woman do? I know.
你最喜欢的菲利斯时刻是她扮演圣诞老人那次。是的，她的单人访谈。听听她是怎么说的。她说那是她最喜欢的单人访谈之一，因为剧本里并没有写她应该哭。她说当她谈到自己有多么想扮演圣诞老人时，眼泪就忍不住流了下来，因为她深深感受到了菲利斯这个角色有多么渴望扮演圣诞老人。太美妙了。我知道。菲利斯，我跟你讲，伙计，这个女人有什么是做不到的？我知道。
She's such a great performer. Okay. Wow, I didn't realize that. All right. Well, for our listeners who are new to the podcast, we have talked a lot on here about what we did in the background of scenes. We had a lot of time to kill because we were all in one big room together. We were all in the background of each other's scenes. And Phyllis happened to have just gotten a new house.
她是一位如此优秀的演员。好吧。哇，我之前没意识到这一点。好吧，对于刚收听这个播客的新听众，我们之前在这里讨论过很多我们在场景背景里都做过些什么。我们有很多时间要打发，因为我们都在一个大房间里。我们都在彼此场景的背景里。而菲利斯正好刚刚买了一栋新房子。
And she was constantly searching for things for the house. I'm talking lamps, patio furniture, rugs. And, well, for a long, long time, she was looking for a gate for her driveway. Yes. It was an intensive online search, and we all weighed in about it. Every day, there'd be a new gate we'd have to look at. Does it swing out? Does it slide? What is it made of? Well, we got a question about Phyllis's gate, and that just cracked us up. And we shared it with her. It's from Anna R. in Fresno, California. Anna said, after listening to the second drink of Michael's birthday, it reminded me about Phyllis's gate. We've heard so much about this gate. What does it look like? I know. Weird question. But it would be really. really appreciated. So Anna, this question really tickled Phyllis as well, and she wrote us to answer you. The first thing she said was, my gate question mark, which cracked me up. She shared with us that after all of those days and weeks of us all looking at pictures and videos of driveway gates, it was actually the gentleman who installed her yard fences who suggested the gate that she
她一直在到处找房子的东西。我说的是台灯、露台家具、地毯。而且，嗯，很长一段时间以来，她一直在为她的车道寻找一扇大门。是的。那是一场密集的网络搜索，我们所有人都对此发表了意见。每天都会有一扇新的大门需要我们来看看。它是向外开的吗？是滑动的吗？是用什么材质做的？好吧，我们收到了一个关于菲利斯的大门的问题，这把我们逗得哈哈大笑。我们把它分享给了她。这个问题来自加利福尼亚州弗雷斯诺的安娜·R。安娜说，听完《迈克尔的生日》第二杯后，让我想起了菲利斯的大门。我们听了太多关于这扇大门的事。它到底长什么样？我知道。奇怪的问题。但我们会真的非常感激。所以安娜，这个问题也把菲利斯逗乐了，她写信给我们来回答你。她说的第一句话是：“我的大门？”，这把我逗乐了。她跟我们分享说，在我们所有人看了一天又一天、一周又一周的车道大门图片和视频之后，实际上是安装她院子栅栏的那位先生建议她使用
ended up using. Oh, yes, she said he helped her design it, and it was the perfect look for her house. Anna, to answer what it looked like, she said, her house is mid-century modern. So she just went with a simple wooden gate. And here's a little important piece of detail for you. The slats of it went horizontal, not vertical. There you go. Amazing. I love that Phyllis's gate got a question in the middle back. I do, too. She was so confused. She was like, my gate? Well, we also got a lot of mail from people pointing out that the character of Phyllis was pretty shy in early seasons, but then as the show goes on, you see her really like push back against Angela. She gets pretty judgy of Pam and pretty frisky with Bob Vance. So we asked her, how does she feel about the
最终采用的那扇大门。哦，是的，她说他帮她设计了这扇大门，这正是她房子需要的完美外观。安娜，如果要回答它长什么样，她说，她的房子是中世纪现代风格的。所以她只是选了一扇简单的木门。这里有一个对你来说很重要的细节。它的板条是水平铺设的，而不是垂直的。就是这样。太棒了。我真喜欢菲利斯的大门能在中段被问到。我也是。她当时困惑极了。她就像是在说，我的大门？好吧，我们还收到了许多听众的来信，指出菲利斯这个角色在早期的几季里相当害羞，但随着剧集的推进，你看到她真正开始回怼安吉拉。她对潘姆变得相当挑剔，对鲍勃·范斯则相当风骚。所以我们问她，她是如何看待
evolution of her character? And here's what she had to say. I really loved how my character is Phyllis evolved. I think that as I gained more confidence in my work and was watching, and learning on the set, that my personal confidence grew stronger and therefore the character of Phyllis had more layers to her. And also the writers, like I said before, saw my personality in different ways. Some saw me as shy. Others saw me as frisky. Others saw me as bitchy. So, Anyway. And I also, I loved how Angel and I were combative with each other. And in real life, we were not combative at all. We were good friends. But I love the combativeness in the storyline. Yeah. I think Phyllis really evolved in the nine seasons and was, and I was very happy that when I look back on it, it was pretty, pretty wonderful. I really enjoyed it. Well, I do love that she shared that we weren't combative in real life. It's always nice to get that information out there.
她的角色演变的？她是这样说的。我真的很喜欢我的角色菲利斯是如何演变的。我认为，随着我对工作的自信心增强，在片场不断观察和学习，我的个人自信心也随之增强，因此菲利斯这个角色也有了更多的层次。而且正如我之前所说，编剧们也从不同的角度看到了我的个性。有些人认为我很害羞。其他人认为我很风骚。还有人认为我很刻薄。所以，不管怎样。而且我也很喜欢安吉拉和我彼此针锋相对。但在现实生活中，我们一点也不针锋相对。我们是好朋友。但我很喜欢剧情里那种针锋相对的感觉。是的。我认为菲利斯在九季中真的演变了很多，而且我很高兴，当我回过头来看时，这一切都相当、相当美妙。我真的很享受。好吧，我真的很喜欢她分享说我们在现实生活中并不针锋相对。把这些信息传递出去总是挺好的。
But we did have a lot of fun being frenemies, you know, on the set. Well, I wanted to share an article with you guys that I read, and I told Phyllis that I read it and wanted to share it. The article was from AARP, and they asked Phyllis, quote, one of the appealing things about the office was that it treated its older characters with the same respect, are comedic lack thereof as the younger ones. And here's what Phyllis said to that. I felt kind of ageless there. Occasionally they would make note of the fact that Phyllis was older.
不过我们在片场作为“亦敌亦友”确实玩得很开心。好吧，我想和你们分享一篇文章，是我读过的一篇文章，我告诉过菲利斯我读过它并想分享出来。这篇文章来自美国退休人员协会（AARP），他们问菲利斯，引述如下：“《办公室》吸引人的地方之一在于，它对待剧中较年长的角色的尊重程度，或者说其喜剧色彩的缺乏，与对待年轻角色是一样的。”菲利斯对此是这么回答的。我在那里感觉自己仿佛没有年龄。偶尔他们会提到菲利斯年纪比较大这件事。
They called me Granny Goose one time. But in general, I think creator Greg Daniels and the writers did a great job of keeping the characters fresh. They didn't dwell on age. They didn't. Yeah, we were sort of in this time capsule. Like we could exist anywhere. Yeah. And if there was a joke.
他们有一次叫我“鹅大妈”。但总的来说，我认为创作者格雷格·丹尼尔斯和编剧们在保持角色新鲜感方面做得非常棒。他们没有纠结于年龄问题。确实没有。是的，我们某种程度上置身于这个时间胶囊里。就像我们可以在任何地方生存一样。是的。如果有笑话的话。
and you were older, that wasn't your only bell to ring. Yeah. You know? Well, I just love that, Angela. And then finally, everyone, Phyllis wanted to say this. She said, I do want to add that I loved every minute of being in the office for nine years. It changed my life in a positive good way. It gave me a career, a new career, when I never even believed acting was ever going to happen for me.
而且你当时年纪更大一些，那也不是你唯一的出路。是的。你知道吗？嗯，我真的很喜欢这样，安吉拉。然后最后，各位，菲利斯想说这些。她说：我确实想补充一点，我喜欢在办公室度过的九年里的每一分钟。它以一种积极美好的方式改变了我的生活。它给了我一份事业，一份新的事业，而我以前从不相信自己能当演员。
and I am forever grateful to Ken Quappas and Greg Daniels and all my co-workers to have shared that part of my life with them. I really, truly loved every moment, and I still miss it. I miss my coworkers, and I miss the creativity of it, and I'm forever grateful for it, and it was all by God's grace, too. She's the best. I love her. I love her. I miss her. I do, too.
我永远感激肯·夸帕斯、格雷格·丹尼尔斯以及所有的同事，能与他们共享我人生中的那段时光。我真的是由衷地喜欢每一个时刻，现在我依然想念它。我想念我的同事们，想念那种创造力，我对此永远心存感激，这一切也都是上帝的恩典。她是最棒的。我爱她。我爱她。我想念她。我也是。
Well, before we go, I think we have one last thing to discuss, and that is the best. is what does the NBC website say about what happened to Phyllis after the show ended? Oh, yes. So, yeah, on the NBC website, it says Phyllis, after locating her long-lost daughter, moved with Bob to St. Louis to have a relationship with her. She now works at a yarn store and gives knitting lessons. Well, I love that. I do love that. But how should I say this?
好吧，在我们结束之前，我想我们还有最后一件事要讨论，那就是最棒的部分。NBC网站上是怎么说关于节目结束后菲利斯发生了什么事的？哦，是的。所以，是的，在NBC网站上说，菲利斯在找到了失散多年的女儿后，和鲍勃一起搬到了圣路易斯，以便与她建立亲密关系。她现在在一家毛线店工作，并教授织毛衣。嗯，我喜欢这个结局。我真的很喜欢。不过，我该怎么说呢？
They might need to update that after the paper comes out next week. Yeah, they might. No spoilers, but they might want to update it. Yes, you all will know what we are referring to very soon. Be sure to check out the paper this Thursday, premiering on Peacock. And be sure to join us next week for our breakdown of the pilot of the paper. All right, well, everyone, thank you so much for joining us in our tribute to Phyllis Lapin' Vance. and thank you to Phyllis Smith for answering everyone's questions. We just love you.
等下周《The Paper》播出后，他们可能需要更新一下那个设定。是的，他们可能会。不剧透，但他们可能真的得更新一下。是的，大家很快就会知道我们在说什么了。请务必收看本周四在Peacock首播的《The Paper》。并且请务必加入我们下周的节目，一起剖析《The Paper》的首播集。好了，各位，非常感谢大家加入我们，向菲利斯·拉平·万斯致敬。也感谢菲利斯·史密斯回答大家的提问。我们太爱你了。
Loved hearing from you, Phyllis. And the questions were so great. Thanks again to everyone who writes in for these All About episodes. They really help us craft it. And we love you guys. Yeah. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
很高兴听到你的声音，菲利斯。而且这些问题都太棒了。再次感谢所有为这些“关于一切”特辑写信的听众。它们真的帮我们构思了节目。我们爱你们。是的。我们下周见。到时见。感谢收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《Office Ladies》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。